ma quanto può fare caldo in una giornata
sola poi ciò sta lampada che per fare
video minchia ti spara flash a in faccia
dio bono aggiungiamo piu difficolta
ancora il suo gioco come se già non
bastasse bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo video sono farage ei pedaggi
siamo su the world game iv
sono passati anni dall'ultima volta che
ho fatto the words are the game
ve lo spiego molto sinceramente sto
gioco è la rovina new game non due big
stack io e lei oltre al fatto che sto
gioco fa veramente schifo ci hanno messo
anche uno che parla dei ragazzi allora
proviamo a fare sta roba visto che è
sempre stato capace io non ho capito
cosa dovrei fa a devo prendere prima la
chiave e vuoi andare a 6 mi chiama già
impossibile
c'è già è già sold cos'è sta roba come
dovrei mai riuscire a parlare una legge
tatro hanno messo le animazioni puoi
cadere nei baratri adesso hanno fatto
sti miglioramenti perché siamo nel 2017
e i videogiochi sono migliorati un sacco
che bello cioè fatta a teatro ragazzi
c'ero anch'io fatta non so come ma va
bene questo mi sembra ancora più
incasinato però ce l'ho fatta a fare
quello di prima non vedo perché non
debba riuscire in questo appunto alla
ramayana detto male ok ok
anche gli acquisti dice poi ok ragazzi
fermi ne esistono i check point questa
la differenza di gigantesca rispetto ai
giochi di prima ma grazie a dio
se io magari guardassi prima di andare
avanti a caso c'è un muro che ve lo
infilo bellamente nel deretano visto che
non so adesso mi sono complicato la vita
ed ho pure tornare indietro
porca eva fatto quanti anni mi si
vogliono che finisca livello scusate che
sapeva o kay aperto col muro di prima
perfetto tra i punti servono una sega
inter gioca in realtà caracas o bucando
devo tornare indietro è [ __ ] ma
[ __ ] burton ha veramente ma da zero
ma mi chiama dai raga io vi sono
complicato la vita andando in
quell'angolo staff è mara meglio fammi
fare le cose giuste perfetto dove devo
andare modo tornare indietro ok mi
sembra che sono riuscite a prendere un
check point e nel momento più sbagliato
della vita ma non ce la posso fare
bastano dai messaggi ti ammazzo la
famiglia cioè io veramente soggiorno a
roma infatti ma perché sono andato lì a
destra li mortacci via ragazzi questa
canzone che sente di sottofondo la
sentirete anche al mio funerale come
fatta cadere due volte che c'era il buco
era piccolissimo cadeau a prescindere
cioè com'è possibile a gesù
buon piano
[Musica]
no no no no no no no no no no porca
vacca siamo secondo lee quanti ce ne
sono di livelli e va a fan cuore va
un'ora e me sembra meno male che c'è la
check point perché sennò quanto può
essere difficile un gioco del genere
ragazzi ve lo dico il primo world league
è innestata una cosa più è stato
l'inferno sceso in terra l'inferno sta
roba ci si avvicina molto
lei per stanare anche sopra scusa ai la
e l'altra parte delle corse con la roma
e l'acqua quella c'è anche l'acqua
cos'è sta roba ma ea annego a sarebbe se
arriva alla fine annego va bene sarò ma
non la sapevo però ti deve morire la
famiglia zio di capirla starò fino alla
finale società adesso il ghiaccio
ah ok non sa non ti manda direttamente
contro il muro che allora diverso lavori
poker ma che ca so che avete tutti
pensato che avrei detto ma che cazzo è
infatti la scelta azzeccata
porca vacca ma quante incasinato il
ghiaccio rega
[Musica]
ho fatto le cose incredibili mi riusciva
mai più nella vita ma ok calmi tutti no
perfetto no no
se riuscissi ad andare piano magari per
poche grandissimo ora vai giù per
cortesia ma giuda per la parte giu
dall'altra parte sì l'ho preso l'ho
preso gesù grazie non so veramente come
ho fatto non fate domande va bene così
se riuscissi a perfetto perfetto
grandissima però adesso incredibile
adesso ragazzi credo che ci sia la parte
più o meno impossibile credo e poi lo so
ok e abbiamo gravato i money come sempre
ma che ora ma basta quanto 2 resto
livello 1 scusatemi ci pensavo di aver
finito tutta la vita adesso su quanto
ora sto mica di livello se va beh ma già
prima era impossibile ma ci manca solo
questo come perché mi devono chiamare
adesso li mortacci tua
a [ __ ] ok questa è la mia ritorno era
uno che mi chiamo nel momento in cui sto
giocando regime e lungaro la avevano dei
richiami dopo mezz'ora mentre la
benissimo ciao tra quanto deve durare
star agonia ma poi scusa mi facevi a
perché ho preso poi termine ripristinava
solo due di soldi non capivo perché ok
portare ma questa è veloce questo era
veloce però l'ho fatto l'altro che era
lento no perché magari se non parlo sono
vivo ancora va bene facciamo si domanda
88 conferma o lei o lei fratello ho
preso la chiave anche stavolta che non
so dove andremo a destra ok no perché
ogni tanto più le chiavi ma non capisco
cosa però non lo capisco dopo questo
credo sia abbastanza easy credo poi non
lo so c'è una trappola che compare
all'improvviso non cade bene era una
presa per il culo sto livello per
dottore tutto indietro grandissimo adoro
questo gioco di me non ce la farò mai ve
lo dico porca vacca quanto gli ho detto
lo zio mezz'ora mezz'ora sua sorella non
ci fa ma porca eva stai zitto tanti
problemi per fini al suo livello cioè
incredibile da quello che non non posso
usare come in pokémon fune di fuga
esiste ancora fune di fuga in poker
li mortacci mia forse riesco a passare
velocissimo cosa aveva fatto
cosa farai ove gli osti momenti da pro
agile che non ho capito dove li tirò
fuori ma ok non avevo preso i soldi ok
fermi che deve gravare tutto non grave
una sega a destra c'è ancora un altro
check point che ho mancato la parte di
destra
ci mancava solo questo guarda cosa cosa
c'è e cosa c'è c'è un livello sott'acqua
ma sei serio zio
eccola qua la odio ve lo dico già
l'acqua la odio perché è lentissimo
quando va in acqua
[Musica]
great game la tua madre no non ho
sbagliato ho sbagliato buon dio mi ha
fatto ripartire meno maiano ha fatto
ripartire da qua perché uno sbagliato
ero ritornato al menu principale penso
non avesse salvato
ci sono rimasto di merda ok raga meno
male ma vai vai vai vai zio vecchio zio
perfetto
piano piano piano piano piano piano
piano perfetto ragazza sto facendo
egregiamente non so perché nonostante
l'acqua è che l'acqua incasina
abbastanza odiose a si muove si esce il
terreno c'è si muove a il pavimento
cos'è sta roba qua quanto può essere
incasinato sto gioco
ok cosa cosa va mancato all è thomas ha
fatto mettono indietro non ci arrivano
mai priolo ci sono arrivato va bene
ragazzi all e sono [ __ ] quanto 2 alto
livello basta quante parti chacha è
impossibile ma vabbè ma dai
c'è un allagamento se quanta roba
ok fino alla chiave almeno ci sia o no
no no no no no no non averlo dimenticato
che a fuoco non sono affogato va bene ma
mica sarà bagarre i tornei e 3 brut
porca put stai zitto devi stare zitto
ok lo ha toccato da toccato oddio che
ansia
ok ok ok ok perfetto
perfetto
cosa ho aperto tua madre ammala mi fa
piacere coeva ok dai cos'è sta roba
cambia direzione pure ma ci mancava da
qua ci manca solo cambio di direzione
guarda ma dopo pato mi sono salvato
malissimo perfetto perfetto
ok l'ultima chiave poi ho aperto la
porta alla fine in teoria hepburn
spero di sì sì sì ho visto visto o anche
quasi preso tutti i money che potevo
collezionare in questo livello ma è
incredibile
abbiamo sbloccato la porta finale adesso
manca solo quella per finire il livello
1 chiaramente sia tutto sto traguardo
per almeno il primo l'abbiamo finito
ok
veramente sto gioco e una sudata cos'è
sta roba
ok grandissimo costo facendoci quanto
sono forte oggi
raga oggi è oggi va così oggi fa vj
vince non c'è niente che ora kakà quanto
fatto di suchan questa parte
matt o veramente carina eh vabbè quanto
mi sembra di giocare ubriaco perfetto
occhio che alla fine pure indietro ma
sei serio la cover come facciata da
indietro zio maraga sto male se non ce
la faccio a me ne vado cioè impossibile
la gamma che cazzo cio oggi oggi sono un
fenomeno non so perché ecco appunto
fatemi godere questo momento da pro
gamer perché non è che ce ne saranno
tanti altri la mia vita però deve averne
perfetto no c'è la ragazza alla fine
sono in teoria sono alla fine poi boh
non lo so ok ok ok ok per grande no li
mortacci mi avevo presi tutti quanto è
difficile sta parte
[Musica]
ma qua